welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
priyanka regalia and in this episode we
will integrate dialogue flow with 2 leos
messaging service one of my friends uses
Twilio messaging service and requested
that I walk him through setting up
Twilio bots with natural language
understanding based on dialogue flow so
here we go again
we are going to work with the same
appointment scheduler chat pod and
integrated with Torrio's messaging
service so that our users who choose to
text us can get the same experience as
the ones who are using us on web and
Google home we are in our agent
let's click integration this time we are
going to click on to Leo's text
messaging service the pop-up has some
instructions click on start copy the
request URL and put it in the twill use
programmable SMS there are more
instructions if you click on the link it
takes you to the detailed screenshots
and how to set it up but for now let's
just do it ourselves the first thing you
will need is a Twilio account if you
don't have one created and then log in
from the dashboard click on all the
products and navigate to programmable
SMS once you're on the programmable SMS
dashboard click on SMS I already have an
appointment scheduler messaging service
setup here but you can just create one
for yourself provided a name and in the
use case select chat pod interactive
two-way let's click on the messaging
service you created to assign a phone
number
use the Add button to buy a new phone
number or just use an existing number if
you have one click through the US
selections and you should have a number
assigned now we click on the
configuration to integrate dialogue flow
enable inbound settings in the request
URL copy and paste the URL that was
generated by dialogue flow in the
integration section and save it now copy
the service ID
number and the odd token from Twilio
dashboard and paste them in the dialogue
through integration console again once
you're done click on save and start yay
our bot started successfully now it's
time to test her bought via text
messages so we will use the number we
assigned to our messaging service and
run through that example again hi I
would like to set an appointment for
3:00 p.m. tomorrow driver's license
great we received a confirmation all
right so today we integrated our
appointment scheduler chat pod with
Twilio messaging service enabling our
users to set an appointment via text we
managed to provide an exact same
experience to our users using our bot
from the website or via text well that's
the win
that's it for today join me in the next
episode for deconstructing chat BOTS
where we will learn more about
fulfillments if you liked this video and
want to see more subscribe to our
Channel
[Music]